what's up we're at Exotica with Sony the
Circa guy and we're gonna interview
these degenerates let's bring them back
to Christ does body count matter does
body count matter
um
it depends on what bodies it's like ugly
guys random were they homeless were they
your girlfriend like the number 40 count
I don't know pull up the notes I know I
do have them in my notes
okay maybe like 16. you're at 16.
bodies wow wow I'm like at seven I'm
very low how is your relationship with
your father
he's cool we're cool wait are you a porn
star um I'm an only fans girl I do my
own porn how long have you been doing
that
what's your body count
um 17 17 yeah so like what do you look
for in a boyfriend somebody who's
emotionally intelligent and empathetic
um a nice dick good sexual chemistry
super loyal spoils me and takes care of
me I'm rich okay but you have to have
more than that or the money
um famous too there's a lot of Rich
famous guys but they don't treat me
right and I don't like them
I can beat up your men the guys that
text you I can beat the [__] out of them
that is a good quality to have though I
do appreciate being protected and
feeling protected when we get married
and have kids do I always need to be
there do you always need to be there
does the dad always need to be there I
would prefer so yeah of course was your
dad always there with you are you close
with them my dad died oh I'm sorry yeah
but I was when growing up
um kind of yeah but I want a good daddy
oh there's another one hi what do you do
for a living so I dance and model what
are you looking for in a boyfriend like
I'm a famous Rich YouTuber is that good
someone that makes me laugh and really
really good sex and that'll keep me and
if you make food
I have erectile dysfunction from all the
Cults probably not sorry
if we can't smash it's over what's too
quick it's nine seconds quick long
enough no no I need to go for a few
hours a few hours every day
we're not black men are you close with
your family a little bit what do they
think about what you do now honestly
most of them don't know so what do they
think you do find out after this
interview do you guys believe in God yes
of course are you religious I'm
spiritual Jesus is King what the [__]
Jesus Jesus is King what the [__] not
religious all about Satan baby get the
holy water [__] burn her all right
boys real quick just listen up there's
this brand new thing called The Tick
Tock creativity program so for every
thousand views you're getting on Tick
Tock right now inside of this program
they're paying you one dollar AKA a
thousand dollars per million views so
there's people making ten twenty thirty
thousand dollars a month off of this
from Simply reposting Tick Tock so I
know a lot of you guys have never edited
you may have never even posted a video
in your life so what I did is I went
ahead and I created a bunch of different
clips for you to use so that all you
need to do is download them and then
repost them on Tick Tock and have money
coming in so I'm Gonna Leave a link at
the top of the description for this free
Discord server where there's the free
tutorial video going into it and then a
link to all the clips for you to
download so definitely go check that out
and back to the video if you watch porn
duh I watch porn well that's what I be
here what do you do for work I work with
coin we do nfts and digitizing for adult
content creators we also work in the AI
porn industry we're playing around with
AI chat Bots and AI porn stars and
metaverse stuff you know full body scans
we'll let these porn stars be an avatar
of themselves in the metaverse does body
count matter no no in a girl no no no no
no the higher the better you think so
yeah it means the shoes desirable and
you know those guys towards the end of
the body count I bet you they don't care
what the you know what that [__]
was when they got it your wife it
doesn't matter how many people she slept
with before no no more the better yeah
like ideally more BBC or more ypc
I don't know man I you know try them all
right try them all you got to try them
on you see Adam
bro it's my buddy I was on this podcast
I got the most views but then he uploads
that he's letting his wife get black
would you ever do that do you're married
no she got black by another man
got married well I mean if my wife's
black how does that matter
black [__] in her after they got married
another plug I don't understand like I'm
still it's flying over my head Adam 22's
wife
they did a porn shoot but they're
married so my wife married she get PPC I
don't know I don't ask does body count
matter no I don't think so it depends
depends who you're asking I'm asking you
I don't think it matters no John do you
think it matters I mean for the girl
yeah
she's at 100 dicks in her that's like
too much okay now here's the thing
though 99s are right though here's the
thing a girl that is having sex with you
as her boyfriend she's gonna have dick
from you a hundred times but if she's
having dick 100 times for a bunch of
different guys she's still taking the
same amount of dick but but some dicks
are black some dicks are Chinese some
dicks are white it's different dicks I
don't know I think I think's likes to
have a good time it seems like you're
limiting her I don't know but is she
going to heaven
oh where it's one of these wait no no no
no no we're just joking we're just
joking wait what what are you guys
evangelicals or some [__] I was like
does he look like an Evangelical no you
guys could be incognito
what's your body count I couldn't tell
you after I got before I got into porn
it was seven after I got in porn I
couldn't tell you oh when did you get
into porn like four years ago four years
I've shot over 300 scenes so oh so
that's a lot of dick yeah it's a lot of
dick
do black men have bigger dicks do we
have bigger dicks I could just feel that
your dick is bigger than ours combined I
can just feel this
Jason's before either definitely never
had sex with him we've never had sex no
okay well I mean did y'all see brigzilla
that's what y'all need to get in here
brigzilla God like Google brigzilla he
got huge pain hey let's go break silence
we got a few questions for you brick why
do they call you brick Zilla
I could dig a wild guess stick as heavy
as a brick are you a porn star sir
actual facts okay how long you been
doing this four years and you better
than him
I ain't better than nobody I'm just
better than me every second of the day
you heard does body count matter and a
wife talking about like your wife taking
too much dick what you talking about
that bother you or it doesn't bother who
are you talking to I'm brickzilla it
doesn't matter next question what do you
think of adam22
just got married and then his wife slept
with someone the week after for a porn
video
his wife's love Jason love oh I kind of
saw that dick what's the question you
let your wife get plowed the week after
you got married I mean I'm not that type
of dude man nah not at all I mean but if
you that type of dude you that type of
dude you wouldn't because I'm not that
type of dog uh how do I get started you
sell um pills I have an issue do I sell
pills how do I get like brazila how do
you get like brickzilla you go to Texas
then you go back in time then you tell
your mother to pick one of somebody from
my family as their father and did you
get back and then you beat Brazil so
you're a porn star um I'm actually an
independent only fans Creator do we
already interview you no you did not
did not does body count matter for
for like in a partner like getting
married getting married I don't think so
because if you get married at 18 your
body count is going to be different than
if you get married at 30 right why do
women lie about their body count
probably because men make stupid
standards about it what's your body
count I have no idea like ballpark I
literally could not ballpark it like a
thousand probably less than a thousand
uh I would say between the ages of like
18 to 22 maybe like I don't know 60 80.
I have no idea
um how's your like does your family know
what you do uh most of my friends uh
some of my but not all of my family what
does your family think of it they're all
really supportive actually pays the
bills it does it's actually a side job
for me what's your main job I'm not
going to reveal my main job oh that's
fine it's like a normal job we're
getting kicked out we're getting booted
yeah awesome we're going to talk about
it all right thank you so much good luck
what's going on all right so we got to
complain about some of the questions
you've been asking the girls inside okay
yeah just don't you guys don't need to
record this don't play the game yeah
it's not that big of a deal apparently
you asked some questions inside to some
of the girls that felt that you were
being disrespectful whatever you guys do
we get so many you guys that come
through these things yeah shooting
podcasts and stuff yeah you guys can't
come back in okay once you disrespect
our staff you can't stick around did
they say what we said you said you just
asked some disrespect it was the
Christianity question was it the girls
in the cage which demon was it every day
guys yup you just can't be on the
property anymore okay okay well that was
quick yeah and we got what we needed
like I think we got a video we can't
fight this we try to like do some of
these like before we did yeah are you a
porn star yes I am
regardless
[Music]
so have a nice night yeah yeah so we got
kicked out of a horror convention I've
never been more sad in my life what are
we gonna do what are we gonna I mean it
was free they're like you're John Circa
here's a stamp I was like this is the
most disgusting place I've ever been to
like the women literally had roaches
coming crawling out their [__] we're
being nice we asked them hey are you
saved did Jesus save you that wasn't
that rude was it no I could have been
more honest I've been like you're a
[__] we had a list of questions that we
didn't even get to I mean I think it
went perfect the problem is these women
they like to troll us and when we troll
back they can't take it are you guys
both in the porn industry yes yes how
long have you been in it six years six
years what about you spoken since last
April what do you do only fans are like
PornHub I do fans I'm also a dancer is
this your girlfriend I know
we just met are you about to go shoot a
scene we're thirsty so we're gonna go
find a bar
and get thirsty for like alcohol we're
gonna get wrecked yeah and that's funny
my name is together my name is Ricky
Rosso she said she wants to get wrecked
wreck it wrong
like the Disney cartoon yeah you don't
watch Disney's no no
I love teenagers do you like teens I
mean
are you religious at all no what does
your family think about you doing porn
uh my mom was a stripper
um you have great tits my dad is dead so
yeah yeah they're fine you like toxic
guys yes why do women like toxic guys uh
I have daddy issues
get in the kitchen [__]
is it okay if I'm like verbally abusive
just verbally you [__] [__] can I beat
it like that I'm gonna cry and then I'll
call you tomorrow take my number
how do I become more toxic what do I
gotta do buddy you
you you're not even close yeah
you gotta start choking and slapping
them in the bedroom
now you don't ask hey mind if I slap you
no kidding no no do it and then say was
that okay look in her eyes green imagine
you're hitting it from the back and the
wings just she flies away
a butterfly net
let's get out of here hopefully we
brought some of these ladies to Christ a
lot of broken Souls here tonight you
have any final thoughts women's socks we
love women don't jerk your dick to any
of these hoes that's Haram I'll see you
later
home oh my God there's a big [__]
crack in the first shot I'd rather
riding on the wall won't last long yeah
the feelings
[Music]